hey everyone i have a really interesting
interview uh today with uh chad hodge so
welcome chad
thank you
listen um i've been doing a series of
interviews on cancer and you have a very
interesting story so i want to share
with everyone what happened to you
um and
before we get into the details you had a
i think it was like a 15 centimeter
tumor in your lung right which is
roughly almost six inches
and uh
why don't you just kind of tell us at
the very beginning what happened i think
uh
you weren't sure what was going on you
went to the doctor you had a scan and
and tell us what happened
yeah so basically in
this was august of last year i went
i had some pain in the
right upper portion of my abdomen
to the point where i thought i had like
maybe a gallstone
and then so i went to the doctor who
they did some tests and found
what looked like to them was an
infection
in my lungs so the first thing they
asked me is if i had been vaccinated and
you know if i had trouble breathing and
i was like
no trouble breathing uh
why and they're like do you think and i
asked you know do you think i have covet
they said it's a possibility so they did
a covet test and then
they did a bunch of stuff i did a
[Music]
sonogram a cat scan an x-ray
and at that point they still were
uncertain
uh due to the rarity of the tumor that
you know eventually they found out what
it was
um they assumed that it was some sort of
infection
and so
the reason i had gone to get it checked
out was just that pain in the upper
right portion of my abdomen which turned
out that the tumor was so large
it was pressing on a nerve
and transferring the pain to the front
uh
top right portion of the abdomen
and so i did what is a
[Music]
biopsy but you know they put you in this
cat scan because they take it from the
lungs so it's kind of
not the most
pleasant experience i could imagine
so they did the the biopsy and at first
they said well it looks like a tumor
and at that point uh you know the
diagnosis with the doctor was due to the
size
was not
promising
he was very much
you know we'll see what we can do
hopefully
[Music]
we can operate and you know we'll see
what treatments are available and stuff
like that but you know kind of like
moderate your expectations kind of like
i don't know don't get your feeling was
like get ready to die you know and
everyone's like all right
thank you doc
right yeah thanks for that
and then um luckily you know the doctor
that i found was very
fast
and he was very determined on handling
the situation as rapidly as possible and
as thoroughly as possible
so here i'm based in northern italy and
there's several hospitals that work
together
and he had already set up with um
a thoracic surgeon
that is one of the better ones in italy
and so i was super happy when i met him
he was very competent
and they ended up removing the tumor and
even at that point
i was then transferred to another
hospital which is a cancer research
facility
and there
again they were just you know what it
turned out to be was the carcinocoma
of the lung and i think the the
technical term is primary pulmonary
carcinocoma
because it originates in the lungs so
it's primary it's in the lung it's
pulmonary and it's a carcinosacoma
which accounts for
i was told about 0.3 to 0.7
of all lung cancers that are diagnosed
which is already only like 14 to 20
percent of all cancers that are
diagnosed so so this is so extremely
rare
very weird
and i forget um
after the
surgery you get the histological exam
where they evaluate all the tissues and
stuff like that and there's some
indicator
that they give you a percentage you know
up to like 25 percent that's very
aggressive
uh below 25 is like moderately
aggressive and then below 10 is like not
aggressive mine was 85 percent
so it was just like
extreme aggression i guess
so so so question at that point i mean
what's going through your mind i mean
that's uh
i could imagine the amount of fear that
kind of comes up with that is this crazy
high i mean
yeah um
a that's a tough one i'm very stubborn
so
the i'm very combative and very
competitive so the second
i found out that you know the second my
doctor said you have cancer and it's
lung cancer and it's a really bad
situation and i was like okay
that's the best that is the best
viewpoint that is so good
yeah and immediately i went into full
research mode
i had been following your videos for a
long period of time so i understood
you know some of the research regarding
sugar and cancer and carbohydrates and
how that turns into glucose and how you
know
tumors feed on glucose uh i guess
there's also another video where you
know there's the
scot
metabolism which also you know the it
can use ketones
as well as so i'll just clarify that for
everyone who's watching that doesn't
know about scott um
there um
there's some data out there that talks
about
um
a very unique
weakness within the cancer cell
there's a very a vulnerable area in a
cancer cell
because it differs from a normal cell in
that it needs a very uh specific door or
pathway
through an enzyme
to feed the
membranes of that cancer to keep it
going
and so um
so there's this so we did some research
in europe using um an inhibitor of this
enzyme called scot
natural and i put that data out there
and i just actually i will be releasing
a video this week on the result of the
study that we did on mice in europe
and
basically you're using compounds that
are blocking this pathway and not
creating a toxic effect and we compare
that to
one of the most powerful chemotherapy
drugs which actually you took by the way
so anyway i'll let you continue um
so to go go ahead continue
yeah so uh
immediately when i got the diagnosis i
went to full research mode to just do
every possible thing i could
to better my circumstance
you know after the histological exam
also
and researching primary pulmonary
carcinoma
[Music]
there's not much information out there
and the information that is out there is
not
promising
they estimate about a
seven to twenty-five percent survival
rate
um and that's within five years right i
mean that's just making it up to five
years
yeah yeah yeah cause they consider five
years being a success
yeah yeah i guess you know i was talking
to one of the
uh
oncologists and
apparently it's it's just all statistics
right so when you have
when you've had cancer you have a higher
increase statistics that have cancer
again
and then after two years that drops
after three years it drops again after
five years you become like a normal
percentage of you know the baseline
society percentile of possibility of
getting a cancer
and so i thought that was a interesting
piece of information
but at that point i found one of your
videos that
you could donate to that research that
was taking place in
europe and you got the cancer diet
and i followed that
like it was
a religious text and i put that in my
diet i was doing a fast 24 hour fast
i was eating mainly salmon tuna
and you know sometimes chicken
and gigantic bowls of salad just a
ridiculous amount of kale vegetables
uh taking the scot inhibitor so that was
like green tea
uh i forget the other ones yeah we have
the uh phytonutrient in green tea
alpha lipoic acid alpha carcinia
cambogia which is
um another term for that is
hydroxycitrate so there's a number of
compounds and even garlic
with allison all these things are
inhibitors of scots so you took that as
well as doing the fasting and by the way
i'm going to put a link down below for
those of you that just want a copy of
that
but again i have to make a disclaimer
um we're not making any claims that this
will do anything for you and i am not
selling these products i never intend to
do that so you'll have to
use this as your
basics for uh doing additional research
and deciding
under the care of your doctor okay good
yeah absolutely by the way
what was interesting um
also the first oncologist that i met i
met with
a
specialist in carcinosacoma and it's
typically a uterine cancer
so that's what she was a specialist in
and when i met with her she had an
intern
and mid our meeting she got called for
an emergency and the intern was
continuing to gather all the information
and i asked him at that point i was like
you know what i'm curious about is
we know that sugar
affects how tumors grow because i had to
do a pet scan and basically you inject
me with radioactive sugar
and that sugar lights up on the pet scan
and it shows you where the tumor is
because it starts
eating that sugar and it lights up
and i was like if if this is known why
don't why isn't the first thing you tell
somebody with cancer like don't eat
sugar
and he went into this very long complex
um
discussion about the metabolism and how
if you starve the the cancer you
actually starve the healthy cells
and he was like but you'll you'll have
to ask the doctor when she gets back
and so the specialist returned and i
asked her the same question and she was
like yeah well
you know there was this dr milano that
did a a huge study on
the effects of taking out sugar but you
have to take out all sugar from the diet
and it had a great effect on cancer
the only problem and she was like you
can research it and give us the name and
you can look it up and you can get the
studies and stuff like that but
since it hasn't been you know broadly
researched it's not part of their
plan so they can't actually prescribe it
as
a
handling for this type of situation i
was like okay it works but you can't
tell you it works so i get it
so and i went on
mini fast
took out sugar completely from the diet
and
the first
time when i went to go
see then they transferred me to a lung
specialist
and this is when they were discussing
whether or not i would get a juventus
chemotherapy
and the first thing since that i've been
several months from my surgery
he was kind of upset
because it was probably too late to do
the adjuvant chemotherapy so i had to
get another cat scan due to that how
aggressive my tumor is that it likely
spread
um so we would have to reevaluate after
another cat scan because he was like
certain it was
had spread already and it was somewhere
else in my body
and so i did a cat scan completely
negative
and it was just you know throughout the
entire process of every doctor i talked
to it was
a miracle to them about how much i had
beaten all the odds
of this type of cancer and they were
super impressed
and then even when i went to do the
chemotherapy because i was you know i'm
gonna do everything
possible so
my reasoning at the time was okay well i
feel fine i i feel it's gone completely
i had already had this you know kind of
like it's gone it's not coming back i
handled it with the surgery and the diet
and i don't think it's going to return
however you know there's this doubt
that you have and
the doubt is really
there from what the doctors are telling
you that you know you have a very high
possibility of the cancer coming back
and you have to be you know very careful
and
there's nothing you can do other than
hope that it doesn't return
um
and so beating all those already i was
ecstatic getting that first cat scan was
just like all right so
there it is again
it's nowhere else
and then i did the
adjuvant chemotherapy which was cheese
platinum and vinorelden
and the cheese platinum is
so it's pronounced chief platinum i
thought it was cis planting but i guess
i had to pronounce wrong it could be
okay you know i'm not
a medical doctor in any way shape or
form
so that's a really that's one of the
most powerful chemo drugs in it so it's
pretty nasty stuff
it was harsh
for me
i had about a week of
being miserable
just low energy
irritable
not wanting to do anything
nausea
however in
speaking to the doctors
typically how it goes is way worse
and the reason why
i believe that it was going so well for
me is i found a study that was being
done in germany regarding
fasting and
chemotherapy where they do it
conjunctive like they do it together
where you fast
during the time period where you get
your injections and so what i was doing
is i would do a 48 hour fast
before my
injection
and then 24 hours
you know i'd have my injection and then
i want to eat for another 24 hours a day
later i would have my first meal
after so that's a total of 72 hours that
i would fast when i was having my
injections
and
the doctors were very impressed with how
i handled the drugs
you know i never had any negative
effects on my kidneys on my liver which
are the main things that
these chemo drugs attack
i never lost all my hair which
they were basically like yeah you're
gonna lose your hair but don't and
you know uh
so
all those things uh
made the experience a lot easier even
though it's definitely not an experience
i would
recommend somebody to uh to have but
did you did you um
um what was the longest fast that you
did was it a week
yeah i think uh
five and a half days more or less was
the longest pass they did
during the chemo it was more difficult
to fast that long
but before after my surgery and before
the chemotherapy i was doing
you know once a month uh i would do a
prolonged fast of like five
ish days
uh and then also weekly i would do a 48
hour 72 hour fast
um
and every day
okay
how was your weight at the time did you
did you
how did you deal with your weight loss
well luckily i had weight to lose so
it wasn't that big of a deal for me uh
you know i probably have another 40
pounds i could easily lose before it
started being like a real problem
at the time
before my surgery i weighed probably
like uh
210 pounds
and then at the end of all the fasting
and all the chemo and stuff like i
weighed like 180
okay it wasn't
you know for my height i'm almost six
foot so 180 pounds but it's not that
yeah big big deal yeah
interesting now before um
i know before you even got the cancer
you
your diet was i mean it wasn't perfect
but it was somewhat good right you were
doing
i think maybe one mil a day or a
keto with
very often i was doing
keto pretty much
almost all the time and allowed myself
you know cheat days every
one month or three months so i was
you know as far as
you know my friends go i was very strict
on my diet even though i felt very
relaxed about it it's not really like a
big issue for me
i don't have this
i have to have
sugar or something like that i probably
at the beginning but
you know i've been doing the keto diet
since
maybe 2012.
well good thing that they don't have a
lot of carbs in italy that's that's the
saving grace for that
yeah yeah they don't have much pasta or
pizza around here and that's for sure no
um so
question um right before
you started noticing the symptoms that
was in 2021
um did you have any
major stress going on at that point
well
more than that more than your average
life stress um
there is uh there was a situation where
i was doing
the type of work that i really enjoyed
doing
um however
this work was not
financially supportable
so i had to stop that and
take on a second job for some debt that
i incurred so
not being able to do that
kind of like life passion that i have
was
i had taken a big toll
stress wise and that was you know
literally
three months four months before the
diagnosis
that's fascinating i don't know if did
you see the recent video i did with fred
he had cancer and um a genetic type and
right before
right before he got it went through some
massive stress so because i was like
his diet was pretty good so there must
have been something else that kind of
set the person up right for a weakness
within the immune systems because stress
literally paralyzes your t cells so
since your body is always battling
cancer all the time if you shut down
your defenses the site opens the door
for
all sorts of things to happen
right
yes
i was i was watching that same video and
i've noticed that also in a lot of my
friends and family
you know they'll experience a stress
event and i know
a month or two later or right after they
have
some physical trauma that they have to
handle
yeah it's incredible um
what about um
your lungs have you ever been a smoker
have you ever
had injury to your lung have you ever
been in a polluted area for a long
period of time just curious
in my 20s i had probably a little bit
more fun than i should have
but
heavy smoker wise no and this was the
biggest concern that the doctors had was
that there was no real
reason that i should have any type of
cancer of the lung because
no injury to the lung no
you know i smoked a little bit but maybe
[Music]
a pack every two or three days for like
a couple years and for them that was
just like i had never smoked
according to the metal it was like
literally they did not believe
they had anything to do with it
i was in the construction industry for a
while so there was chemicals and stuff
like that but not
a large exposure and i was always very
careful with masks and
you know making sure i was not inhaling
heavy chemicals
well another good point about living in
italy is they don't have any secondhand
smoke so that's really good too we've
got no pasta and no
secondhand smoke i remember walking to
the train station like
i was like i had to get some air because
it was like everyone's like smoking
around me i'm like wow that's
incredible yeah it's very much like it
was i guess in the 80s and 90s when
you know now they don't allow smoking
also inside here so that's good uh but i
remember being a kid of you know people
smoking in restaurants and yeah on
planes and
it's like oh my gosh
i remember my dad in the station wagon
smoking in the front seat just it's all
just coming back and uh
it's like i have to open the window
yeah but um this is actually an amazing
story i think it's gonna inspire a lot
of people who um
maybe um either have cancer and just
give them hope there's something that
they can do about it or other people
that just want to prevent cancer and
have some some things to do and follow
and research so i'm gonna what i'm gonna
do is i'm gonna put um
that eating plan down below for those
those people who want the protocol and
eating plan and again i'm not making any
claims
so just check with your doctor but um
this has been an awesome interview i
really appreciate your
sharing and spending the time to do this
because i think it's gonna
you know give give more people
the other side of
other strategies you can do simply
because once you have cancer you know
you have everyone in the brother telling
you to do different things and you're in
a state of confusion and
in fear
yeah and very depressing it's not uh
it's definitely not an uplifting
situation and the medical industry is
very much
depending on the cancer that you have
you know obviously i had a very unique
situation
but
every doctor it was really hard on both
me and my wife because everybody we
talked to was just like oh well it's
great that you don't have kids and it's
like
cool things
i guess
i know it's like um i think sometimes
people have a hard time of uh
communicating the appropriate thing and
they always
they they don't realize that that's not
the best thing that oh good thing you
don't have kids yeah we're really good
about we're really thankful we don't
have people yeah yeah yeah that was that
was really on my mind right now that was
yeah you know
but i really hope that um
people
will inspire to
eat better especially when it comes to
cancer
understanding how it
is a metabolic disease and the more
research that goes into it i actually
saw
pfizer is even researching medications
that mimic fasting in the body rather
than just not tell you to eat
you know let's make a pill that mimics
the
effects of fasting and it's basically in
case
you know because cancer you end up
losing a lot of weight and you get very
skinny and so fasting
can be difficult if you
don't have the weight to lose so it was
a way for
you know what they're trying to find is
a way for you to fast
without inhibiting the amount of
calories for the body so you don't have
a problem with being underweight but
i just thought it was interesting that a
large drug company was researching drugs
on how to mimic fasting when it was just
like okay well i'll just not eat how
about that
exactly exactly that is interesting
awesome well
thank you so much and uh we'll we'll
love to do like a follow-up interview um
and just to see how you're doing as well
sounds great yeah it was my pleasure